que l'éditorialiste alexis poule à
alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
nouveau report de l'application de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
ah mais aucun abandon prévu comme le
réclament les responsables des cinq
centrales syndicales
l état a droit dans ses bottes l'état
fou l'état totalement qui a perdu pied
je crois que c'est ridicule de vouloir
continuer dans ces réformes d'un autre
temps
regardez ce qu'il se passe ce virus ne
finit pas maintenant il est question
peut-être d'un possible confinement nous
avons un couvre-feu l'économie ne va pas
se relever l'économie mondiale est
rentré dans une zone de turbulences pour
des mois peut-être des années des
secteurs entiers vont s'effondrer et
vous avez ce gouvernement qui fait comme
tout comme si tout allait bien madame la
marquise et comme si seulement trois
mois de délai de cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage allait suffire à
éviter le pire
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage si
jamais elle devait avoir lieu elle
précipiterait dans la précarité
un nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
stratosphérique comparé à ce qui est
déjà le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui si le gouvernement était un
gouvernement qui gère qui prévoit qui
est aux commandes et qui a un plan
stratégique alors il devrait penser à
comment lutter contre la précarité qui
va exploser dans les mois qui viennent
comment faire pour que des millions de
français ne connaissent pas ni la faim
ni la pauvreté sachant que l'emploi va
se faire rare or vous avez là des gens
et je ne comprends pas qu'ils sont assis
autour d'une table et qu'ils discutent
du monde d'hier comme si tout allait
continuer sur des réformes qui n'ont
plus lieu d'être aujourd'hui s'il ya une
chose à faire avec cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage c'est de prendre le
papier c'est de le mettre dans la
machine à recycler essaie de récupérer
le papier pour faire quelque chose
d'autre avec mais certainement pas de
dire qu'on va décaler de trois mois ces
mesures qui de toute façon ne sert plus
à rien aujourd'hui
et pourtant il continue et ils sortent
et je crois que si les partenaires
sociaux utiliser ce temps utile
maintenant à planifier la praye qu'ovide
la suite des opérations dans une
économie de basse intensité de base
croissance dans une économie
incertaine où les frontières vont se
fermer ou les échanges ne seront plus
jamais comme avant
alors il faut penser à comment sauver
les travailleurs français comment faire
que en période de faible intensité
on n'est pas toute une génération qui
sombre dans le chômage et dans le
chômage
sans aide c'est parce que c'est ça la
réforme de l'assurance chômage c'est de
dire simplement vous allez être formés
pendant quelques mois et puis après vous
trouverez du travail mais il y en aura
plus du travail
si on regarde ce qui se passe c'est bien
simple les entrepreneurs ceux qui ont
des bars des restaurants le monde de la
nuit
même dans le voyage le spectacle etc
combien d'entreprises vont fermer vous
mettre la clé sous la porte
eh bien on a l'impression encore une
fois que le gouvernement ne prévoit rien
du tout et continue sa feuille de route
qui n'a plus aucun sens aujourd'hui plus
aucun sens aujourd'hui et
malheureusement jean castex fait comme
si tout allait bien jean castex que je
le rappelle c'était monsieur
déconfinement qui avait filé les clés du
déconfinement au cabinet de conseil bain
and company on a vu le succès on est en
pleine deuxième vague
c'est une catastrophe l'école rien n'est
prévu pour la rentrée après les vacances
scolaires et tout est à l'envi et cette
conférence sociale elle est surréaliste
on a des gens autour d'une table qui
discutent comme si le monde allait
normalement comme si rien n'avait changé
depuis cette crise sanitaire qui a tout
changé
est ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
c'est parler de runes universelle c'est
voir comment on va éviter que les soupes
populaires soient débordés dans les mois
qui viennent comment on va faire pour
que les entreprises ne mettent pas
massivement la clé sous la porte
or aujourd'hui le plan de relance qui
est sur la table ne prévoit que 0 8 % de
la somme totale des milliards totaux
pour lutter contre la précarité et
l'extrême pauvreté rien hélas rien n'a
été discutées à la conférence sociale à
part peut-être la cgt qui demandent
l'augmentation du smic
mais encore une fois ce gouvernement
refuse d'augmenter les minima sociaux
parce que ça éviterait le retour à
l'emploi de certaines personnes qui
préférait prendre les minima sociaux
mais on n'est plus dans ce monde là on
n'est plus dans le plein emploi depuis
longtemps
or il continue de faire croire que ce
monde-là va continuer c'est incroyable
de voir cette hypocrisie
ce déni de réel de la part des
dirigeants politiques qui sont là pour
prévoir alors il ya aussi à une fois de
plus la réforme des retraites
aucun abandon
non plus elle doit revenir dans le débat
fin 2020 débile 21 mai où sera ton
finalement à ce moment là c'est un
nouveau brûlot en perspective finalement
non encore une fois cette réforme des
retraites anachronique qui doit elle
aussi être mis dans la machine à
recycler le papier c'est fini on n'en
parle plus et pourtant cette réforme des
retraites si on continue elle doit être
liée à la croissance
lll est fait sur l'optimisme sur le fait
que l'économie va créer des richesses et
sur le fait qu'on va pouvoir faire de
l'argent avec de l'argent
alors oui ça marche pour les
milliardaires comme jeff bezos ce pour
certains fonds de pension sans doute
comme blackrock et autres qui profitent
de cette crise pour faire un maximum
d'argent avant que on ferme le cinéma et
que tout le monde s'en aille mais ça ne
va pas durer
la réforme des retraites encore une fois
c'est quelque chose qui est dangereux si
on l'a fait en l'état actuel c'est
simplement dire à des générations
entières qu'elles n'auront plus de
retraite et qu'elles travailleront
jusqu'à la mort et là encore que fait le
gouvernement est bien il veut continuer
ses réformes c'est de feuille de route
alors que même un pays comme la grande
bretagne qui a inventé le thatchérisme
est en train de mettre le thatchérisme à
la poubelle avec des lois sociales pour
essayer d'éviter le pire à ses
travailleurs et qui a commencé déjà à
quitter l'europe et à fermer les
frontières en comprenant bien que le la
donne du monde avait changé mais
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'état on a des
gens qui ne comprennent rien à ce qui se
passe et qui sont complètement largué
excusez moi du terme et qui n'ont aucune
aucune mais vision stratégique de ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour prévenir et
pour sauver l'avenir de ce pays parce
que c'est pas en continuant à faire des
réformes d'inspiration néolibérale qu'on
va sauver l'avenir de ce pays maintenant
c'est la solidarité qui doit primer
c'est aller chercher l'argent là où il
est quand il sert à rien dans la sphère
financière et éviter que des millions de
concitoyens rentrer dans l'extrême
pauvreté
or encore une fois hypocrisie discours
vide quand on écoute jean castex on est
sidéré en fait de ce vide intersidéral
où ils nous présentent des réformes qui
n'ont plus lieu d'être comme si c'était
la feuille de route qu'il fallait
continuer moi j'ai peur je pense que
nombreux français ne comprennent plus ce
qui se passe en haut il faudrait
peut-être commencer à à se poser des
vraies questions notamment vis-à-vis des
partenaires sociaux je suis étonné de la
part de la cgt ou de la cfdt
qu'il se soit assis autour de cette
table qu'il soit resté et qu'il n'est
pas claqué la porte en disant mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait là qu'est ce qu'on
fait là je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une crise sanitaire qui mérite
un peu d'un peu plus de hauteur un peu
plus de réflexion stratégique que cette
conférence sociale que nous avons vu
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup alexis poulain je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes et